en haití en la vida política 10 de años
y años siempre fue muy compleja y muy
complicada por ejemplo muy claro desde
nuestra independencia en 1804 hasta el
día de hoy
un 25 por ciento de los jefes de estados
de ahí que pudieron terminar su mandato
sabemos que estamos en una espiral de
des de inestabilidad crónica en el caso
del expresidente doble weiss él entró en
la vida política desde como lo podía
llamar un outsider era un empresario y
un hombre de negocios que no estaba muy
activo en la vida política
ahora tenemos que entender que los
políticos haitianos nunca tuvieron un
compromiso con el experto de la
democracia no podemos decir incluso el
ex presidente guillermo es también no
tienen ese compromiso con la democracia
porque siempre lo que quieren es buscar
derrotar al otro para poder estar en su
espacio y es justamente lo que estamos
tratando de denunciar que haití tiene
que seguir o entablar el camino hacia la
democracia lamentablemente es un asunto
es una muy compleja y como haitiano
joven
nunca vivimos una situación así está en
suerte vivimos golpe de estado pero ver
un presidente asesinado no nunca vemos
eso la última vez fue en el año 1915 por
eso hoy en general el pueblo haitiano
está un poquito y estar muy